are you learning a lot about yourself
this is what I'm hearing from people
being that sprinting and being
sequestered and being alone and spending
a lot of time isolated I'm learning
about myself what have you learned about
yourself I have learned I have learned
that I have learned that I'm a close
talker
I woke talker I did not realize I was
that much of a close talker because now
with social distancing I realized that
as I'm speaking to people I'm kind of
like approaching them I was like mildly
aware of and now I'm just like II can
relax
you have seven years of professional
acting training they taught you how to
project they got it they can hear you
and so that's one thing I've learned
about myself what does he is he a
tractor beam what's wrong with you why
am i okay you know my son who's 14 it
keeps giving me [ __ ] because he notices
that when I talk in this situation if I
talk talk on a virtual call a zoom or a
Skype that I talk as if I'm talking into
an older telephone you know I do worry
about you because I know we've talked
about this you're a huge sports fan yes
I know massive sports fan and sports
sports are gone right now there are no
sports what are you doing how are you
getting your fix here's your's okay
here's what I'm doing
here's what I'm doing Conan what I'm
doing is I'm trying to fill in the gaps
of my sports knowledge right so it's
going anywhere from okay you know the
90s like late 80s 90s early 90s NFL not
my strong suit for whatever that sports
trivia game just falls in my lap I want
to be ready you know if I'm gonna do HQ
online or something like that so right
before the Dallas Cowboys dynasty in the
mid nineties I'm a little axe so pretty
much goes from the Pittsburgh Steelers
to the Cowboys I'm gonna
fill in that spot yeah right and then
read up 2000-2008 I have another gap so
I'm gonna fill those gaps in then the
other thing I've been doing is I'm
brushing up on those nice obscure sports
just in case the Tokyo Olympics happens
I want to be up on the Badman also also
it helps me when I make a big
international action movie and I have to
go to Malaysia I'm gonna be able to go
hey guys how about that how about that
doubles championship with goola goola
goola kitchen with the over hand sir I
just want the Malaysians to go very good
with the badminton you know